Is one of those historical oddities whereby a piece of land ends up becoming a
kind of Russian Island in the middle of the European union,
a place surrounded on all sides by countries, belonging to the European union,
and also NATO, something like Vladimir Putin's, Trojan, horse friends.
We are talking about a place with a population of less than a million,
and which is economically insignificant $7 billion of GDP, or in other words,
some $7,300 of GDP per year.
What's up.
Say that besides being the land that saw the birth of the philosopher,
Emmanuel Kant,
this place located almost 400 kilometers away as the Crow flies from the great
Russian landmass is a little more than a giant military base today.
Its value as a commercial, financial or industrial,
and clave is practically insignificant despite being located in the center of
Europe. If the Colleen and grid of blast were an independent country,
it would be poorer than countries like Peru or Gabon.
To give you an idea it's per capita. GDP is less than half of that,
of neighboring Poland and much of its economy depends directly on the Russian
armed forces station.
As you can imagine, back in the days of the cold war and the Warsaw pact,
this enclave was under Soviet sovereignty and that was not a problem today.
However, things are very different.
Glenn and Greg has become a challenge for its neighboring countries,
a political and above all big military challenge friends.
Would you like to know more about this little known and amazing place? Well.
That's good.
Friends of visual politics to understand what glean and Greg is today.
We cannot ignore its history. So before we get to Kaliningrad,
we have to talk a little bit about Prussia, Germany, and also the Soviet union,
This Russian enclave, which was under German sovereignty until 1945.
We sounded by the Teutonic Knights in 1255 under the name of Koenigs Berg
during the crusade to conquer and Christianized Prussian territory.
From that moment on the city,
Koenigsberg prospered as an important commercial enclave.
It was part of the Hanseatic league and was the Capitol of Prussia for 300 years
until in 1815 pressure became a founding state of the German Confederation and
fuss. The city came under German sovereignty. However,
the history of Koenigsberg took a bit of a turning point in 1945 during the
second world war between January and April, 1945,
very harsh battles before that culminated in the total destruction of the city
and the capture of almost 100,000 German soldiers by the red army.
Then after the end of the war, in order to control it strategic port,
which was also free of ice during the winter,
the Soviet union annex to this place,
drop to the name Konigsberg and renamed it in honor of the Bolshevik
revolutionary Mikhail cleaning with the name that we all know today.
So what do think happened after.
The Russian annexation?
Well.
The Germans live in,
in cleaning rod were forcibly expelled from the region between 1947 and
1948.
And the blast was colonized with Soviet families from areas destroyed by the war
and by the military, a lot of military, yeah, that's South Joseph Stalin road.
The point is that this is how Kaliningrad basically became what is today a huge
amphibious military base Naval air and land,
a base that saw its strategic importance only increased with the end of the
Soviet era and the fall of the Eastern block.
Since then it has become a Russian stronghold in the heart of now.
[Inaudible].
A Russian army in the middle of the EU.
Pay attention to this data,
nearly 20,000 soldiers stationed and 58 Naval units among which we can find
destroyers for Gates, missile launches, submarines, torpedo boats,
and assault ships more than 800 tanks and 1200 armored vehicles,
345 artillery systems of over a hundred millimeter caliber and almost 200
aircraft and helicopters friends.
These are just some of the details of are known about the current Russian
deployment and this kind of a macro military
Because the inventory could actually be higher because the Euromaidan riots in
Ukraine and the annexation of the crime mere tension between Europe and Russia
escalated.
This led to a kind of arms stockpiling in 2014 that has continued to this day
and has left a trail of news headlines like this.
Trump confirms more us troops will be sent to Poland, DW,
Russia forms, new division deploys,
more ships and aircraft and Kaelin and grit reports,
L R T U S tanks and troops headed to Lithuania for
lengthy deployment stars and stripes. Yeah.
Diplomatic relations between the West and Russia are colder than ever,
but pay special attention to this headline.
Russia deploys Eskander nuclear capable missiles to Colin and grads.
Are I a Reuters?
In addition to this list of trips that we've mentioned,
Putin's government has deployed what is considered to be the cream of its
critical weaponry to Colleen and grit, a type of weaponry that you only deploy.
If you want to raise the threat to something like a state of imminent war,
that is a level of threats that takes us back to the times of the day.
Cold war. We.
Above all about the Iskander missile launch brigades missiles with nuclear
capability and whose launch systems are capable of attacking simultaneously with
32 such projectiles in a single salvage.
These missiles have a range of between 380 and 500 kilometers depending on their
variant. The Iskander K for example, can reach up to 500 kilometers,
which would allow them to attack practically any position in Poland, Latvia,
Lithuania. This obviously includes NATO military bases in the area. Furthermore,
the launch system is mobile located on a kind of truck,
which allows them to change locations and be undetected with some.
Ease.
And remember that the danger is not only in the controversial is scanned as they
have gleaned. And it is also a real air raid fortress.
If the Russian military industry has stood out for anything in recent years,
it has been above all for its S 400 anti-aircraft system,
very advanced anti-aircraft system that Russia exports halfway around the world.
We are talking about a system capable of shooting down almost any enemy aircraft
within 250 kilometers.
And that means that Russia could control the passage of NATO aircraft between
Western Europe and the Baltic countries from its cleaning grid base.
Wow.
The fact is that this entire system of land sea and air armaments,
which combines both offensive and defensive equipment constitutes a military
strategy called [inaudible] this strategy or military capability,
which go beyond the acronym anti-access area denial consists of creating a
virtually armored zone where an army is able to control any possible enemy
military movement to the millimeter. And when I say any movement,
I'm talking about land sea and air,
And I'm sure that as you can imagine,
that something like that situated practically in the heart of Europe is
something that is of great concern to the members of NATO,
especially its Eastern European members. To a large extent.
This is indicative of the more strange political relations with Russia.
Since the cold war to give you an idea,
confidence is so low that the Polish army has erected six observation towers
along the border with Kaliningrad and they've done so with funding from the
European union,
each tower is about 50 meters high and equipped with surveillance and tracking
equipment to monitor Russian movements along its 200 kilometer border.
But hold on a moment because if we leave the military retention aside,
the truth is that on the social level, the level of the people,
the picture is somewhat to do.
See.
Since the fall of the Soviet union,
the exchange of people between Kaliningrad and the Polish city of Gdansk has
been constant more than 6 million people poles and Russians from gleaning grad
cross the border every year, just before the post Crimea tension escalated.
After all,
we are talking about cities that are just over a hundred kilometers away by car.
So it was common for the Russian population to travel, to Gdansk,
to buy products that they did not have access to in Kaliningrad. And of course,
you know that when there is such an extensive and continual exchange of
travelers between one territory and another,
well in the end aspects of the foreign culture and society always remain.
And that is what explains why the people of Kaliningrad one of the least pro
Putin and most pro Europe groups in all of Russia.
Take a look,
coexistence, dissipates, everything.
As we have mentioned.
Despite the fact that relations between Europe and Russia collapsed in 2014,
the truth is that cleaning grid has a very European flavor and is much more
international. And open-minded then what is difficult in mother Russia?
Here's an example while only 30% of Russians have a passport to travel abroad.
If we focus only on the citizens of Coleen in Gradle blast,
that percentage rises to over 70%.
This is jus above all to the huge transit of people that has existed since the
late 1990s and early two thousands between Colleen and grant and its European
union neighbors,
Poland and Lithuania trips that beside tourism have a lot to do with shopping.
If there is one thing that makes Kaliningrad stand out,
it is that it is a place where there are not a lot of things to do nor too many
interesting products to buy a situation that was further reinforced in 2014,
when president Putin banned the sale of land multitude of Western legally
European and American food stuffs and products in response to sanctions imposed
on Russia over the mess in Ukraine. And as you can imagine,
this meant a drastic reduction in the variety and quality of goods available in
Russian supermarkets and shopping centers.
So the citizens of cleaning grads who are geographically privileged began to
travel to their neighboring countries so often,
even if it was only to buy Parmesan cheese, come on, bear or ham, the,
we can almost say it became their favorite pastime.
This.
This is much more significant than it might seem at first sight.
Thanks to all these trips.
Russian citizens have had very close contact with the economic,
political and social developments that countries such as Poland or Lithuania
have experienced in recent years. For example,
they have witnessed firsthand the enormous wave of prosperity that these
countries have achieved.
It also means that Putin's NTU revision carries less weight here.
The vision of a hostile Europe coming from the official Russian television
channels. It doesn't gel with the Europe ADV.
I traveled to pull in the lots and see how people relate to Russians.
Everything is fine. There are no problems.
The pools are people just like us Alexander office worker from Colin and Greg
for the guardian.
Because far from what you might expect in light of everything that we've told
you in this video,
the truth is that the Russian government has made the entry of foreigners into
Kaliningrad more or less.
One of the latest milestones in this regard was the introduction of the free
electronic visa in mid 2019 a visa that can be obtained online just four days
before visiting the territory.
This type of visa is available to citizens of 53 countries, including Spain,
Germany, Lithuania, and Poland. I hope the UK is on that list.
It'd be cool to come and see this place. However,
there is no access for citizens of the United States or South Korea,
but curiously there is for North Korea. Anyway,
one of Putin's quirks as it stands,
the military tensions between NATO and Russia concerning Kaliningrad does not
seem to have much relevance at street level.
This is one of those many occasions in which the troubles of the rulers,
the officials,
and some more than questionable interests are super-imposed on what it should be
in reality, a much calmer coexistence in any case. Now it's your turn.
What do you think about a Russian territory full of soldiers,
missiles and warships in the heart of the EU and NATO should Russia and NATO
make more of an effort to understand each other instead of increasing the
military presence more and more, leave your opinion below in the comments.
And if you liked this video,
don't forget to like it and subscribe to the channel as always.
Thank you very much for being here.